monsieur le président bonjour donc on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour parler
environnement et plus particulièrement
de nos forêts à la réunion donc le
département possède plus de cent mille
hectares d'espèces naturelles forestière
un patrimoine à la fois exceptionnel et
fragile exactement je dirais que nous
avons la chance ici à la réunion d'avoir
encore ce patrimoine et il faut le
préserver il faut le préserver parce que
ce patrimoine est d'une grande fragilité
tous ces écosystèmes font face à des
attaques des espèces invasives font face
aussi à heureusement parfois donc la
compression des hommes des braconniers
il nous appartient de faire des efforts
pour préserver donc tout ce patrimoine
forestier et vous savez ce patrimoine
est reconnue sur le plan mondial puisque
le rempart sont classés donc patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco et donc la
responsabilité du département qui est
propriété a malgré tout faut pas
l'oublier de ces hectares dans des lots
de la réunion nous avons la
responsabilité de l'entretenir et nous
le faisons à travers un budget
conséquent puisque ce sont 11 millions
d'euros chaque année le département
consacre donc à la partie forestière de
lille et c'est à travers ses 11 millions
d'euros ce sont des emplois aussi que
nous soutenons parce que nous n'oublions
pas les âges en u19 mais ce que nous
mettons au sein donc de la forêt
réunionnaise à travers des contrats
d'association
il y a près de 1000 personnes qui
directement travail pour préserver
entretenir aménager la forêt de la
réunion et ses aménagements justement
c'est bien connu sont très prisés par
les réunionnais notamment le dimanche
ben oui vous le savez bien nous sommes
tous réunionnais et le crès l'expérience
que nous sommes les émaux aller
pique-niquer
les aires de pique nique sont très
prisés il ya d'ailleurs une belle
chanson qui s'appelle pique nique sur
les volcans que tout le monde connaît
bien qui traduit un peu cette tradition
locale cette tradition réunionnaise
allons pique-niquer avec marmite la
famille et tout ça mais quand on va
pique-niqué il faut offrir justement des
conditions d'accueil
c'est ce que fait le département
partenariat avec le n 9 des aires de
pique nique aménagées entretenu qu'il
faut garder propre parce que là aussi
c'est une qualité de l'environnement
qu'il faut préserver
n'oublions pas que les sites ont bien
sûr utilisé par les réunionnais par nous
mêmes ici à la réunion mais aussi par
les touristes qui viennent découvrir
notre île et il faut le offrez donc une
très belle image de ces aires de pique
nique et vous pensez que ces espèces
naturelles ce peuvent ils sont un outil
important pour la promotion du
territoire à la réunion exactement parce
que l'île de la réunion est très prisée
pour ses montagnes la qualité de ses
paysages des eaux
bien sûr la forêt les remparts le volcan
c'est quand même l'un des volcans les
plus actifs au monde et les touristes
qui viennent ici viennent pour justement
découvrir les hauts de l'île un peu la
plage mais surtout les hauts de l'île
est donc cette richesse encore une fois
mérite d'être entretenu c'est ce que
nous faisons et on peut dire que ces
grands espaces sont également générateur
d'activités économiques
oui parce que dans les eaux nous avons
d'égypte qui fonctionne le gîte du
volcan le gîte de la roche écrite dans
mafate un peu partout donc tous egypte
font qu' il y à de l'activité économique
il y à aussi de l'activité économique à
travers la philly abois
aujourd'hui la syrie de la nf1 produits
du bois du cryptomérias mais aussi
parfaite du tamarin et cette filière
bois doit être soutenue parce que elle
permet aux artisans locaux d'obtenir de
la matière première
cette matière première locale elle est
extrêmement important j'ai moi même
rencontré le directeur de la nef et
ensemble nous envisageons d'amplifier un
peu l'activité de la filière bois donc
ici à la rime d'accord donc là on est
sur tout un ensemble de valorisation
mise en avant de notre patrimoine on
sait que le département de la réunion
est le premier propriétaire forestier de
lille et celle où nf qui est
gestionnaire de ces espaces vont mener
ensemble des actions de protection sur
le terrain notamment pour la
conservation de la biodiversité
oui lavaur et réunionnaises je vous
l'avais dit donc soumises à des
contraintes et notamment il faut lutter
contre les espèces invasives
je salue le travail des ouvriers donc
qui font un travail remarquable dans des
conditions souvent difficiles dans les
hauts de la réunion
grâce à leurs efforts nous pouvons
lutter et préserver donc les espèces de
la réunion et ya un travail qui est mené
aussi avec les agents de vnf pour ouvrir
ces forêts on va dire les rendre
accessibles aux personnes à mobilité
réduite aussi bien sûr parce que la
forêt réunionnaise mérite d'être
découvert et pourra être découverte
il n'y a pas que les personnes valides
qui doivent le faire il faut père veut
permettre aux personnes présentant des
handicaps d'avoir accès aussi à nos
sites remarquables et bien sûr à chaque
fois que nous le pouvons nous demandons
à l'eau à 9,2 permettre l'accessibilité
aux personnes présentant des handicaps
et ce travail est fait je le reconnais
et bien sûr il reste encore à faire
mais sachez le la forêt réunionnaise ce
n'est pas une forêt uniquement pour les
personnes valides
nous voulons que tout à chacun puisse y
accéder et bien sûr les personnes de
handicap en priorité aussi donc il ya
vraiment une démarche avec le
département avec le n9 d'ouvrir ses
forêts de les rendre accessibles mais
aussi on va dire de les faire vivre
c'est-à-dire mener des actions pour le
développement va dire de production
agricole le développement d'activités
coton ristic et également de loisirs sur
ces espaces naturels exactement donc je
vous l'avais dit donc l'activité
économique se développe dans la forêt
réunionnaise mais aussi des activités de
loisirs et à travers ses activités de
loisirs nous offrons des emplois mais
nous offrons une offre touristique
je pense que vous parler notamment du
plan départemental pour la valorisation
agricole des espaces naturels notamment
pour aider l'installation de ruches et
de la plantation de vanille aussi
le développement des plantes aromatiques
et médicinales exactement parce que
l'activité économique s'est aussi de
l'activité agricole dans les hauts de la
réunion en zone forestière il faut pas
faire n'importe quoi nous avons des
espaces naturels sensibles
mais je le dis on ne peut pas exclure
l'humain les personnes humaines de ces
forêts et l'activité agricole peut
permettre aussi de préserver les espaces
et de lutter contre les espèces
invasives
un dernier mot sur le partenariat et le
travail on va dire en cohérence entre le
département et le nf justement pour
valoriser préserver faire des espaces
naturels de la réunion on va dire d
espace unique et emblématique pour notre
territoire
le n 9 et 9 partenaires incontournables
parce que le n9 un savoir faire en
matière d'encadrement en matière de
connaissances aussi de la fourrure
réunionnaise en matière d'encadrement de
nos effectifs et donc je suis bien sûr
conscient que parfois il peut y avoir
des difficultés mais ce partenaire et
fiable et le département nous consacrons
un budget assez important pour permettre
à louannec justement d'accomplir sa
mission dans les hauts de la réunion de
sanaa forêts réunionnaises dans les
conditions les meilleures
moi je souhaite que le n9 et nous mêmes
nous soyons toujours dans cet état
d'esprit de partenariat pour justement
aller encore plus loin parce que je
voulais dit notre responsabilité c'est
de transmettre au gnr générations
futures une forêt réunionnaise de
qualité une forêt réunionnaise réservé
où malgré tout bien nous les êtres
humains on puisse accéder accéder poids
des activités familiales ou personnelles
mais en même temps préservons cette
forêt et lohan ait fait le bon
partenaire pour cela merci